you recently did something that I
thought was pretty cool you posted a mug
shot that was this is a real mug shot
taking of you what year is this uh
probably around 2011-2012 okay let's
take a look this is your mug shot that
you posted
good-looking mug shot the very man that
weird collar yeah yeah yeah by the way
that was also 5:00 in the morning right
I had no idea my collar was popped they
kind of put these clothes on me you go
and you stand there and you do this
thing but uh yeah I didn't realize they
dress you as well when you get a mug
shot yeah
yeah that's fantastic I had my stylist
call ahead he's gonna get arrested he's
gotta look good all right you got to
tell people what did you do that got you
arrested I was on a road trip with my
buddy Ashton who's actually backstage
and my wife founded a bakery in Texas
we're in Dallas and San Antonio bird
bakery in case anybody's ever said yep
and and we had like basically we got
married we had a bunch of [ __ ] left over
from our wedding like table decorations
all this so I was like I'll Drive him
out to the bakery we'll have him there
to open the bakery and we're driving
through West Texas
and we're driving we're driving we're
driving and then we turned this corner
and there's just bright lights
everywhere and there's a massive sign
that says canine on duty all vehicles
will be inspected and I knew at that
moment that I was so you just had stuff
from the wedding what's the big deal
right well I guess I can say this now I
did not just have stuff from the wedding
so so we pull up to the thing and the
guys like where are you going because
we're in a u-haul which is I guess
already very suspicious and and then
we're like oh we're driving to Texas
he's like you're in Texas I was like
right right because I was nervous yeah
sure sure sure and he's like where you
going I was like San Antonio and he's
like what's in the back I go decorations
for tables and chairs and stuff like
that and he goes all right you guys you
know why don't you just go and he looks
over like this and just then officer
with a dog walks out of like one of the
doors and he goes actually hold on one
second and we knew we were that close to
getting away with it and then the dog
comes walking up and I mean he's a sweet
dog I have nothing against the dog he's
really just doing his job but he comes
walking up to the u-haul and he smells
it for half a second and he sits down
and just puts his little cute paw right
on our car and that was the kiss of
death for us
what did you guys have we said like weed
I mean no it's just we was just wheat
it's legal now so yeah now I'll say it
was right we what if it was weed and
doggie treats right that would have
probably kept me it was Jim was jail
okay did you spend the night in jail I
mean the inmates were great
the guards were real [ __ ] but the
guys in there were great what were they
do make any friends yeah I did I made I
made some lifelong friends no it was it
was it was a bunch of guys and you know
I get in there and it's it's late and
and I kind of get in bed and I wake up
next morning and some guy kind of like
shakes me and I I've seen enough jail TV
shows and I was like I know how to
handle this situation so I roll over and
I go what yeah and the guy goes easy I'm
this food here and I go oh all right
thank you thank you thank you yeah and
we're sitting down and we're eating and
one of the guys looks I mean he goes
you're that guy no no no no no I'm not
and he goes yeah you're the guy and I go
no no I'm definitely not the guy goes
yeah you're the Facebook dude yeah and
then one of our sail mates named Baca I
hope you don't mind me saying this vaca
but he goes his Facebook was not
yeah but yeah one guy was like you're
Halle Berry yeah I got offered I got
offered a tattoo and I got offered a
Swede I got offered all kinds of fun
stuff a Swede yeah apparently one of the
guys shelved which is the jail term he
shelved a bunch of weed into jail which
means he shelved it honestly Conan I
don't know why you needed a Swede
explained to you right needless to say I
did not smoke a Swede in jail yeah yeah
okay they did I did not
this is primarily a children's show so I
think commercial break right now much
more with armie hammer after this big
around
you